hello everybody and welcome to the
second part of our python three tkinter
uh tutorial mini series
uh in the last video we made just a
really simple basic window we did it in
eight lines
um which would really take hundreds if
not thousands of lines to create a
window normally
so we can already kind of see the value
of using decanter
but anyway with that we're going to go
ahead and continue on
so the first thing that we might want to
have in our window is people want to
maybe add buttons so let's go ahead and
add a button to this so the first thing
that we're going to do is we're going to
come back over here and
in this initialization we want this
window to pop up you know immediately
okay so we have a class window and it's
really just a frame and we've
initialized this but now what we're
going to want to go ahead and do is in
our initialization we're going to say
self
dot
and then we're going to go init
underscore window empty parameters for
now now init window does not exist okay
so this is not something that's built
into t cancer we're going to
use this and we're going to create this
function right now so we'll come down
and we're going to say define init
underscore window and again we're just
going to pass through a single parameter
can you guess what the parameter is
going to be self that's it
colon
and now we're going to go ahead and say
is self.master.title
is going to be
we're going to call it gui ok
and then we're going to say
uh self dot pack
and
uh basically first of all let's just go
ahead and i suppose what we should do is
to explain what we're doing here so
again so what you have with a
window is you actually have a frame
and then within that frame you put
really windows
and so basically here we're initializing
the window and then um here we're saying
the title of our window is gui so your
understanding of what a window is
where the title of that window might go
is going to be gui okay and now what
we're doing is we're saying self.pack
and what we're going to do is we're
going to say fill equals
both
and then expand oops expand equals one
and basically what this is saying is yes
uh we'll
adjust dimensions as as needed and then
also we're filling up the window
and then we're going to come down here
and what we want to do is we want to
create our button instant
so and then pack we're basically packing
this into our frame okay so we've got um
let's say we want to have a quit button
so we can all not only can we make a
button but we can
go from there into event handling so
we're going to say quit button
equals capital b-u-t-t-o-n's for button
and this button is a part of t cantor so
we're kind of taking button from tkinter
um maybe it would be nice for us to view
that really quick so 34.
just a quick aside tcl keep that in mind
you might want to check that out at some
point anyway tkinter
and
uh buttons probably internet maybe even
in maine i should have found these
before i guess i won't find it because i
want to spend like 20 minutes searching
for that on film but anyway button is a
function within uh t cantor
now again button self again it could be
bajoomba or whatever you wanted and then
we're gonna say uh text this is the text
that will be written on the button so
you could put anything here for us we're
going to say the text is
quit
okay
and then what we're going to go ahead
and do is enter enter and then we'll say
quit button dot place and we want to
place this button
uh at x equals zero and y equals zero
so this will put it at the upper
left so if you're familiar with like css
or anything like that generally what you
do is you start at the upper left and
any additions right or that many pixels
over that many pixels down
okay a little bit different than your
the convention where it's really the
bottom left and then you know x is over
y is up it's not really like that it's
actually x
over true but y is actually down so to
speak so anyway
um
that should be good uh we've got now a
quit button placed it's not going to do
anything but it's there okay so we're
placing that quit button now it might be
a good idea to
once we start saying hey we're going to
use these pixels and here's what we're
going to do blah blah blah it might be a
good idea to go ahead and
specify the default shape of this window
that way as we're kind of placing things
on it we can do the math in our head say
hey this button will fit or i know this
button won't fit because like if you say
we wanted to place this button at x
equals 500 and y equals a thousand well
we saw the previous window the deep by
default window's not that big so
uh it wouldn't even be there okay so
what we're going to go ahead and do is
after we've defined root equals tk next
thing we can do is we can say
root.geometry
geometry geomet geometry goodness i
can't spell
and then here you can specify the
dimensions of this window so we're going
to say it's a 400 by 300 window okay
and then that's really all the things
that we need to change so now what we
can do is let's go ahead and save and
run this
and here's our window now you can see
our default size of our window is
different we can still however you know
modify the size of the window and all of
that
the quit button we can click but it
doesn't do anything but at least it acts
like a button like look at all that like
we didn't have to code any of that uh
you know the button being pressed
pressed in and out shape of the button
the shadow of the button i mean all this
stuff that's going into this window
is pretty impressive so anyway
uh click the x
so that's how we can make a button but
we clicked the hell out of that button
and nothing happened right so now what
we need to do is we have to
give the button an event handling
ability so when someone clicks it it
does something okay that's what the
whole point of a button is so in the
next video that's what we're going to be
covering is uh event handling and making
this button actually you know quit
okay so if anybody has any questions or
comments regarding this video please
feel free to leave them below as always
thanks for watching thanks for all the
support and subscriptions and until next
time